as the curve flattens in texas and
arizona democrats and the media continue
to proclaim doom on covet democrats
declare trump a fascist for enforcing
the law in portland and chicago
and trump has some weird words about
jazlane maxwell i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like the government spying on you
then visit expressvpn.com
to stay anonymous okay so let us begin
with where we now stand
on covet it is perfectly clear at this
point that the case numbers are starting
to alleviate in places like texas and
arizona i'm looking at a chart
from the new york times right now and
what it is showing is that there's a
leveling off that is beginning to happen
in a variety of states
according to this particular new york
times stays
study cases per capita where new cases
are mostly the same
california over the last 14 days mostly
the same
new jersey new york mostly the same
where new cases are decreasing
arizona it's decreasing where new deaths
are increasing
right new deaths are trailing indicators
they're still increasing in
some places like florida and arizona but
again that is because
death usually comes you know within
seven to 14 days after
diagnosis if you are going to die from
covid even in areas where it seems like
the
cases are increasing over the last 14
days over the last seven they seem to be
decreasing so texas is starting to see
a bit of a drop off if you look at the
chart from the new york times
you can see that florida is experiencing
a bit of a drop-off they had a very
sharp spike and now they are beginning
to recede so in terms of hospitalization
rates forms of icus fewer people are
being hospitalized who have it fewer
people who end up in the hospital are
going to the icu
fewer people who are going to the icu
are dying and what this means that
overall the death rates from this thing
seem to be dropping fairly precipitously
now that doesn't mean that it isn't
highly deadly it is significantly more
deadly than the flu by
most available estimates according to
the wall street journal six months into
the pandemic researchers are homing in
on an answer to one of the basic
questions
about the virus how deadly is it
researchers initially analyzing data
from outbreaks on cruise ships and more
recently from surveys of thousands of
people in virus hotspots have now
conducted dozens of studies trying to
calculate the infection fatality rate of
cobit 19.
that research suggests covenant 19 kills
from around 0.3 percent
to 1.5 percent of people infected but
the the generality of studies
is between 0.5 and 1 now it's important
to look at the
date estimates on these things the ones
that have been done later tend to skew
in favor of a lower death rate so the
ones that are done in may tend to skew
between point five percent and one
percent their
uh bevy of studies from may and june
that actually show this thing well below
one percent actually well below 0.5
percent there are a couple studies that
may show this actually even in the realm
of the flu but most studies basically
put this thing in between point
five percent and point eight percent
which is pretty much what i've been
suggesting for a very long time is that
this thing is not
0.1 it's probably between 0.2 and 0.6 i
think has been my sort of
stated estimate of the number of people
who get this who died now again
that includes all of the above 80 year
olds who get it and there the infection
fatality rate is a lot higher
so when you remove people who are in the
nursing homes people who are uniquely
vulnerable
to this thing then you're talking about
maybe three cases in a thousand
in terms of people who die from this
thing okay this is that is that is
really what you're talking about for
people who are below the age of 65
is an infection fatality rate that
probably is somewhere around three and
one thousand people who get it
will die which seems like not an
extraordinary rate
or at least an extraordinary rate high
enough to say that you have to shut down
the entire society for all time
odd infant item until a vaccine is found
i should be frank about this we all
take risk mitigation steps in american
life and internationally we all have to
figure out what are the sort of things
that are worth shutting down
an entire society so we don't shut down
society for the flu
obviously nor should we the infection
fatality rate on flu is about
one in one thousand people who get it
will die of the flu every year right
it's a point one percent
infection fatality rate for the flu so
if it's three
in one thousand as opposed to one in one
thousand is that now high enough that
you shut down the entire society
now if you're talking about something
like ebola then you're talking about
like
five percent of people who actually
sorry if you're talking about ebola the
infection fatality rate
on ebola is like way higher or sars
or mirrors if you're looking at at
various death rates
on on these diseases then some of these
diseases have death rates that are like
20 50 then of course if it were to
spread through the population you have
the black plague
but if you're talking about the
difference between one person and a
thousand dying and three people and a
thousand dying of a disease
that is not the kind of infection
fatality rate that necessitates shutting
down
an entire society so if you're comparing
diseases by in
by infection fatality rate right ebola
for example has an infection fatality
rate it's
a disease fatality rate up to 70 percent
like if you get it you're gonna die
basically
that is not in any way the same thing as
covid
this is important stuff because it is
going to necessitate how we think about
policy
it's gonna necessitate how we think
about policy when it comes to reopening
schools where the infection fatality
rate is way lower than that because
again
if you're a kid the chances you're dying
from this thing are much lower
like as in like a multiple lower than
the flu if you're under the age of five
there's i believe a 16 times
higher chance you die of the flu than
you die from covid so
this should inform our thinking but it
seems like everybody is sort of
determined to panic
at this point and they're using some
data that suggests that
we should be very concerned but i don't
think any of the data suggests panic at
this point like the widespread panic
you're seeing the media's alarmism
suggesting that we're right back where
we were in march and april
no we are not right back where we were
in march and april in march and april we
were seeing nearly 3 000
people at a die right now we are seeing
an uptick a significant uptick from a
couple of weeks ago a couple of weeks
ago we were seeing
somewhere between 600 and 800 people a
day die today we are seeing somewhere
between 900 and 1100 people die a day
so an uptick of about 300 people dying
every day that that's not great
there's also a country of 330 million
people and every day in the united
states in a normal circumstance you have
7 500 people die
every single day in the united states so
differential of 300 people dying a day
while tragic and horrifying is that
enough to shut down the entire society
forever i don't think so particularly
when we have mitigating steps that we
can take like wearing masks and social
distancing which means
the best thing we can do right now is
get back to work wear masks socially
distance
if you are in effect a person who is
uniquely vulnerable
then try to stay home as much as
possible and don't go to crowded areas
but that's exactly the same thing i've
been advocating for literally months at
this point
and yet what the media are suggesting is
the only solution here is full-on
lockdowns now as we're going to see
the evidence that lockdowns are what
actually brought down the
infection fatality rate or that
lockdowns really prevented the complete
destruction of societies
the evidence on that is fairly scanty
we'll get to that in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that sleep is not easy to come by
these days that is why you need the
finest
in all sheets i know you don't think
about your sheets very much right you
just got the ones down to local bed bath
and beyond and you spent too much money
on them or maybe you didn't spend nearly
enough money on them and you just got
the vinyl ones right that
you play a record off of what you
actually need are excellent organic
cotton sheets from bull and branch these
sheets are so good
i cannot sleep on other sheets now what
do millions of americans and three
former us presidents have in common they
all agree that bowling brand sheets are
the softest most comfortable pure
organic cotton sheets on earth
bowling branch cotton is rain fed
pesticide free carries the highest
organic certification which is why it is
incredibly incredibly soft he gets
softer with each wash
by the way because they work with
family-owned mills all over the world to
expertly weave every set of bullet and
brand sheets with the highest levels of
craftsmanship it's quality
you can feel the moment you open the box
again i love the bowling brand sheets
that i've got
they are breathable they are really
comfortable and
they they really make it easy for me to
sleep at night which i need because my
kids are waking me up every five seconds
since they sell direct to you bowling
brand sheets start at just 160 bucks
which is a great price for a really true
luxury brand of sheet i mean these are
like thousand dollar sheets for 160
bucks
plus you can sleep on them for a month
risk free right now you get 50 bucks off
any
sheet set at bullanbranch.com with promo
code ben shapiro spelled b-o-l-l
and branch.com promo code ben shapiro my
name for fifty dollars off bulletin
dot com promo code ben shapiro
restrictions may apply to bull and
branch dot com
for details you will not regret this
okay so how about lockdowns are
lockdowns the solution to this
well here's the thing government enforce
lockdowns really were
probably not the reason why infections
stopped
moving through the population as fast
people changed their activity there's a
point i was making last week that people
were deliberately attempting to
misinterpret because i said it very
clearly
people react in rational fashion to risk
assessment so
if there's a large amount of infection
in your community you are much more
likely to wear a mask than if you are
living in rural texas
what that means is that once people see
the risk materialized then they start to
take action
and this has been true with regards to
coveted lockdowns so the government was
like well we got to lock this stuff down
we're going to lock it down
right the hell now okay but they really
didn't okay there were weeks late on it
people started locking down i mean the
data is very clear on this
people started locking down people
stopped going out to public places
people started wearing masks
before the mandates kicked in human
beings have a
very powerful amygdala a very powerful a
very powerful fear response
that encourages them to take measures to
prevent their own death
and i think we can rely on that for most
people to actually be smart enough to
protect themselves
and the people who are directly around
them in britain this has become a major
controversy
because chris woody who is one of the
the chief medical he's the chief medical
officer for england
he said that the lockdowns probably are
not what caused the decline in the curve
in britain he says the decline in the
curve began before the lockdowns you see
this with masking in a lot of areas that
the declines began before the masking
why because people were taking
responsible action before the mandates
came in so this bizarre
notion that everything has to be
government top down and that if the
government doesn't act then nobody will
the the evidence on that is is pretty
scanty overall
and as we say if you watch the media
covers right now the media's like you
should be panicked you should be
panicked about the case load rising
except explain we only started
re-locking down places like florida and
texas like a week ago
we've already seen decreasing caseloads
we started locking down california again
like a couple of days ago a few days ago
we've already seen decreasing caseloads
so what exactly caused that probably
people started getting more responsible
about where exactly they were going as
they saw the news that the cases were
spiking
and so we've already hit the other side
of the curve in places like houston
even npr's admit admitting as much
according to npr
after a sudden surge in reported coven
19 cases beginning at the end of june
houston's daily case count and hospital
admission rates seem to be leveling off
health officials say they are not ready
to determine if the data are
statistically significant yet but it's a
positive trend
last friday experts were ringing alarm
bells david purse
health authority for houston's health
department said i just want to put in
perspective for those folks who don't
see what the issue is
in your experience you may not know
anybody who's sick you may not know
anybody who's died yet
but here's the bottom line we kept
hearing that all the hospitals were
going to be overwhelmed
then there was a surge unit receded
every seated in arizona it's receded in
texas it's beginning to recede in the
case count
in florida houston hospitals are not
overwhelmed
the icu occupancy in the vast majority
of states is below
80 there are almost no states where it
is above
85 percent which means that we have
actually not threatened
the health systems of the united states
at this point
but you probably don't know that from
watching the media if you watch the
media then basically everybody's gonna
die and if we don't force people to stay
at home
everybody's gonna die and not only that
republicans are responsible for
everybody dying
but that's not statistically correct
it's just not right okay if you look at
the number of infections that have been
detected over the past
couple of weeks what you see is a line
that looks arithmetic in its growth
right it's very large it's a very large
spike in the number of cases that have
been identified over the past couple
weeks
in the united states i'm looking at the
day on day charts
in daily new cases in the united states
and take for example
as of june 30th as of june 30th there
were 46 000 identified cases in the
united states
as of july 17th there were 75 000
reported cases
in the united states yesterday they're
about 67 000 reported cases
in the united states but the death count
didn't escalate anywhere near
like that so i just used june 29th or
june 30th as the baseline
so if you look at june 30th in terms of
the deaths then what you are seeing is
about 726 deaths on june 30th now
remember it's a lagging indicator so
that really kind of measures june 15th
so what you'd really want to do is
measure a couple of weeks out from then
so you'd want to look at like mid july
mid july you're looking at about a
thousand deaths today
right from that from that spike maybe
that continues maybe we see
you know 1500 deaths today maybe we see
2 000 deaths today
i kind of doubt it i think that we've
gotten better at treating this thing in
hospitals
but we're not going to know that for a
couple of weeks one thing is true
the idea that we are back at new york
levels new york epidemic levels where a
thousand people a day were dying in new
york alone
that is that we're not there nor are we
likely to be there
states that have been heavily criticized
like california states that have been
heavily criticized like texas and
florida really
those are states that are experiencing
at their height like 140 150 deaths a
day which is not good
right you don't like that that's not a
good thing but to take yesterday's
totals florida experienced 132 deaths
texas
texas experienced 118 deaths those are
those are bad numbers those numbers will
likely increase
they're not going to increase the levels
of new york you're not going to see a
thousand deaths today in in florida
you're not going to see a thousand
deaths today
in texas particularly because that thing
has already started to
recede in a lot of these states but the
media are invested in a particular
narrative and the narrative
is that everything is going wrong and we
are all screwed the narrative is
basically the nancy pelosi narrative
right nancy pelosi is now calling kova
the trump virus which is just so you're
not allowed to call it the chinese virus
because if you say that it came from
china that means you're a racist but
she's allowed states the trump virus
even though it has killed hundreds of
thousands of people all over the world
did not originate in the united states
and was centralized mainly in democratic
states where the governors did a crap
job
like phil murphy in new jersey and like
andrew cuomo in new york but apparently
it's all trump's fault
i swear the sort of political idiocy
of suggesting the moral idiocy of
suggesting that it's the quote unquote
trump
virus is beyond the pale but that's what
nancy pelosi does here she was
clearly it is the trump
virus well what do you mean when you say
the trump virus
the tribe virus if they if he had said
months ago
let's wear a mask let's not let socially
distance instead of
having rallies and political whatever
they were
then more people would have followed his
lead as the president of the united
states so
what you're saying is that thousands of
americans have died because of
what the president has done or not done
is that what you're saying yeah
yes that's what i'm saying i think it's
clearly evident
it's clearly evident that if the
president had done what exactly
like really what was the president
supposed to do that he did not do
i i'm livid with the trump campaign
frankly that they've not put out a
commercial just showing all the various
governors from whitmer
to jay inslee to andrew cuomo to gavin
newsom
saying openly and positively that trump
gave them what they need which is true
which is true again trump's done a
horrible job in terms of the optics of
covet but in terms of the actual policy
of kovid
other than he didn't put on a mask
himself what exactly is the big critique
here
like seriously what's the big critique
we lost a couple of months because the
cdc
didn't do its damn job and get the test
ready and turned down testing from other
places we are now doing more tests today
than any place on the planet it is not
close
we're doing millions of tests a day in
the united states we've done 47 million
tests at this point in the united states
if we're not doing millions we're doing
certainly
half a million hundreds of thousands of
tests every single day in the united
states
so calling it the trump virus is just
the purest form of chaos politics
and democrats at this point are rooting
for chaos and you listen to beta
o'rourke who is the id of the stupid
democratic
beta still hanging around yeah i'm a
loser but
i have things to say from my mansion
paid for by my father
go better go lieutenant governor dan
patrick
who on fox news said there are more
important things than living
in other words let's get on with the
dying knowing full well that will be
those frontline workers making
seven dollars and 25 cents an hour which
is a minimum wage in texas
there'll be african americans it'll be
latinos and mexican americans
who will be doing the dying right here
in texas this is a death cult
the texas gop only they want you to do
the dying and that's exactly what is
happening in texas right now okay this
is just sick
it's just sick nobody wants anybody to
do the dying the question is
can we have any semblance of a normal
life in an arena
where at at most five to ten people in
every one thousand are dying of covid
right can we have anything resembling a
normal life when if you protect the
nursing homes and protect the most
vulnerable that number looks more like
three in every ten thousand uh three in
every thousand are dying
can you have anything that resembles a
normal life like that i think the answer
is yes
i think you can mitigate the risk and
get that number down from three in one
thousand to maybe
one in one thousand or maybe you make it
so that fewer people are infected with
the mass and with the social distancing
but if bedrock works idea is that we are
supposed to cower in our house until the
end of time
then he's just rooting for chaos and it
feels like there are a lot of people who
are rooting for cass at this point i
don't think haley mack and any the white
house press secretary is wrong when she
says members of the media are trying to
scare you
if you watch the media coverage all you
have seen is that the case
load is rising across the united states
it's about to swamp the system there is
no evidence the system was swamped
anywhere in the united states with the
exception of certain hospitals in new
york
hey that evidence does not exist in
florida it does not exist in houston it
does not exist in dallas it does not
exist in los angeles
the people of the united states have
largely been what i thought they would
be
responsible they have largely adopted
mass wearing this has been true for
months
six in 10 americans say they wear a mask
every time they go out of the house
right now
and that is true in red states as well
as blue states
most americans are being careful about
how they act here
okay but the media are indeed trying to
alarm everybody
and then they downplay any good news
right i mean they're an actual headline
saying that
you know the death rate from covet is
down fewer people are dying as
infections rise
but we shouldn't consider that good news
why should we not consider that good
news i consider that excellent news
i saw a study yesterday that suggested
that death rates in hospitals is down 79
because we've learned how to treat this
thing better that is a really good piece
of news and it should inform public
policy
if a disease becomes more treatable that
means it is less risky to the general
population
is it not right you should hear the good
news and the bad news right you should
be concerned you should not be panicked
the media is pushing panic
and then there are people who are
pushing utter unconcerned i'm not
pushing utter unconcerned
i'm pushing rational concern that means
you take rational action
that's what a lot of members of the
media and the democratic party
apparently are not interested in
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that right now a lot of people are
thinking about life insurance they're
thinking about protecting their family
in case god forbid something
should happen to them but can you get
life insurance right now you can
you personally can get life insurance
right now hal you head on over to policy
genius
as a life insurance marketplace backed
by a team of experts policy genius is
keeping track of all the changes in the
market so you don't have to they'll find
you the right amount of coverage at the
best possible price without the headache
policy genius compares quotes from the
top life insurance companies all in one
place
it takes just a few minutes to compare
quotes from top insurers and find your
best price
this doesn't just save a lot of legwork
you could say 1500 bucks or more a year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape for free so if you hit any
speed bumps during the application
process
they will be there to take care of
everything so if you need life insurance
but you're not sure exactly where to
start head on over to policygenius.com
policy genius will help you find the
best rate handle the process completely
it'll get you and your family protected
hopefully give you one less thing to
worry about these days which would be a
big thing for you
try it today make sure your family's
protected they do all sorts of insurance
by the way they do auto insurance and
home insurance and disability insurance
and get it bundled
go check out policygenius.com
competitively shopping always a great
idea
and particularly a good idea when it
comes to lifeinsurancepolicygenius.com
okay so yesterday president trump
re-upped his daily press conferences he
decided to go out there and do his press
conferences again
the reason that he had stopped doing
them is because he kept going out there
and saying weird things during his press
conference to put it
mildly right suggesting that if you
shine a uv light up your butt or
something that it was going to cure
but with that said the president does
need to show leadership because that's
apparently all the media care about
right andrew cuomo could be the garbage
the most garbage governor in america
which by the way by evidence he is
but as long as he was going out there
and and acting
like a leader on tv that's all that
mattered to folks
so trump going back out there and acting
like a leader is is fairly necessary
here
trump came out yesterday said listen
it'll probably get worse before it gets
better that's true in terms of the
deaths
right because again death is a trailing
indicator it's a lagging indicator so if
you've seen a rise in cases over the
past two weeks even if it's receded
in places like texas florida and arizona
right now that means that you will see
some escalating death rates for probably
the next week week and a half
are those escalating death rates going
to bring us to new york rates not even
close not even close but
here's president trump rightly saying
that it's going to get worse
for a little while here there is no cure
and so we have to be careful
we are in the process of
developing a strategy that's going to be
very very powerful we've developed them
as we go along
some areas of our country are doing very
well others are doing less well
it will probably unfortunately get worse
before it gets better
something i don't like saying about
things but that's the way it is it's the
way
it's what we have you look over the
world it's all over the world
and it tends to do that okay and
president trump also added that
now would be a good time to wear a mask
so finally he said wear a mask does that
mean people will now lay off of him
and suggest that that no it means that
they're gonna say why didn't you say
wear a mask earlier if only he had said
wear a mask earlier this would have
ended all of this stuff
again the fact is the united states has
adopted mass scoring for months at a
higher rate than most of
most of northern europe for example we
wear masks in the united states at a
higher rate than canada does
and mass squaring across the united
states you can't just aggregate the
stats
you can't just say that mass squaring in
new york is exactly like mass squaring
in the middle of rural kansas because
those are two very different areas if
you're in the middle of a place where
people are naturally socially distanced
you don't have to wear a mask as often
so kind of aggregating that stat doesn't
make a whole hell of a lot of sense in
any case here's president trump saying
yeah you know just go ahead and put on a
mask young adults may often have mild or
even
no symptoms they won't even know they're
sick
they won't have any idea that they have
a virus they won't have any idea at all
america's youth will act responsibly and
we're asking everybody that
when you are not able to socially
distance wear a mask
get a mask whether you like the mask or
not
they have an impact they'll have an
effect and we need everything we can get
okay so he finally says wear a mask and
the media comes down on him anyway and
finally
this was the headline that was
completely ignored everybody keeps
saying trump is blowing this why isn't
trump doing x y and z but they don't
actually explain what exo9c are
trump says by the way we have no request
for equipment none across the country
states have what they need
which means he did his job i got
criticized a little bit
yesterday for suggesting that the trump
administration policy was actually not
bad
well isn't it a pretty good indicator
that the trump administration policy on
this is not bad
that governors aren't coming hat in hand
to ask for things because they got what
they needed here was trump yesterday
my administration currently has zero
unfilled
requests for unfulfilled requests for
equipment or anything else that they
need from the governors no governor
needs anything
right now and we think we'll have it
that way till
the end because frankly we are stocked
up and ready to go wherever we have to
go we have nearly
7 000 national guard and military
medical personnel in texas
california florida and arizona that's
helping us greatly
the media won't cover that the media
won't cover the fact that hospitals have
not been overwhelmed the fact that death
rates have gone down and the fact that
the feds have given people what they
need
because that would suggest that things
are kind of working right and the media
don't want that narrative they don't
want it
and by the way we are going to have to
make some tough decisions about how we
live our lives because for all the talk
about vaccine development
vaccine companies are testifying they
may may have a vaccine ready to go
in six months which means that for the
general public it may not be ready
fouchy said this yesterday it may not be
ready
until at least the middle of 2021 and
maybe the tail end of 2021.
you think we're fully locking down like
la is talking about again for a second
time you think we're fully locking down
all the way till the end of 2021 for a
disease that has a death rate in people
who are not
the elderly of three in one thousand you
think that's a thing that people are
going to go along with
forever i have some doubts again the
vaccine companies testified on the hill
yesterday they said well you know maybe
we'll have a vaccine in six months
listen i would love to have vaccine
today
but let's be real about this people are
living their lives every day that you
live your life is a day that you move
toward your death okay every day
still counts it's not as though life
lengthens on the other end of life
like i i get that we want to preserve as
many lives as possible i'm on board with
that
but also we would like to preserve
quality of life that's a thing that
matters
and it turns out that we make risk
mitigation efforts every day and we take
into account risks and then we act
now here is a vaccine ceo explaining to
congress
that yeah maybe we'll have one in six
months maybe not
according to statements from several of
the companies testifying today
and based on the speed at which they are
progressing through clinical trials
it is possible that a coven 19 vaccine
may become available by the end of this
year or early next year
that's a rare bit of good news in this
harrowing time
but while some public health experts are
bullish on the development of a vaccine
we must remind ourselves that plenty can
still go
wrong okay and this would be something
to keep in mind
because you've been told that you gotta
lock down forever or you're gonna die
and that ain't true that's a false
choice alrighty in just a second we're
gonna get to the rooting for chaos which
doesn't just
exist in the level of covid although
it's most clear there it exists maybe
most maybe even more clearly
when it comes to public safety we'll get
to that in just one second first
you know have you been having trouble
falling asleep at night i know why
you know why too it's because you keep
staring at screens right before you go
to bed you got that blue light right the
blue light is coming off the screen it's
keeping you awake
and check your phone in the middle of
the night then you're up the rest of the
night because you were too dumb to buy
felix gray glasses you should have had
felix gray glasses on why
well because it would have minimized the
blue light you'd get fewer headaches
you'd feel better
it wouldn't keep you awake in the middle
of the night there are a lot of symptoms
from spending too much time in front of
screens they can range from headaches
and blurry vision
and dry tired eyes and trouble sleeping
exposure to blue light at night can
lower the production of melatonin which
regulates sleep
this is why you need felix gray felix
gray glasses will filter out 90
of blue light in the most damaging range
and eliminate 99 percent of glare
through a proprietary industry-leading
lens technology only available with
felix gray
felix gray frames they're hand finished
from durable super lightweight italian
acetate
you can order online and the glasses
will ship directly to you with hard case
and lens cloth included you try them for
30 days risk free
if your screens aren't easier on the
eyes then send them back for a full
refund so you got nothing to lose they
look
great they wear great and they really
will alleviate all the strain on your
eyes get rid of that blue light go to
felix grayglasses.com for the absolute
best quality blue light filtering
glasses on the market that's
f-e-l-i-x-g-r-a-y glasses dot com slash
ben
felix grayglasses.com shipping and
returns totally free at felix gray
felix grayglasses.com go check them out
right now okay so meanwhile the rooting
for chaos continues with regards to
public safety
so you may have noticed that chaos has
absolutely continued in portland
we got chaos in chicago we got chaos all
over the country as the
idiot defund the police crowd and their
democratic and media allies
have made cities across the united
states significantly left safe
for american citizens well in portland
basically the media ignored for two
months for two rolling months they
ignored the chaos in portland
and it wasn't just two months i mean
antifa's basically been running the
center of city of the city
at the behest of mayor ted wheeler for
years andy no a friend of the program
he's been reporting on this he's been
beaten up for his trouble in portland
for reporting on the fact that nancy
would do things like stopping drivers in
the middle of the street
in broad daylight and the authorities
were told not to do anything
well basically the media had a strategy
with portland we're going to ignore all
the chaos because we kind of like antifa
up until the point the feds come in at
which point we will pretend the feds are
the aggressors
that's been the narrative promulgated by
the media and it's fully crazy
the only reason to do that is because
you are rooting for chaos and you're
rooting for chaos because you think it's
going to get rid of trump
the more chaos there is the more you
think that trump will go i
i cannot come up with any other
explanation for this because if a
democrat were president you presumably
would not be rooting for chaos in this
way
okay mike baker reporting for the new
york times with a ski helmet and goggles
on her head
alison hyder recounted how she had told
relatives she planned to stand at the
rear of protest in downtown portland
but in the early hours of tuesday the
grandmother of five found herself right
up front locking arms with other mothers
dressed in yellow so the media have been
running cover
for all of these these kind of protest
moms
who are standing up front of the protest
and then they've been ignoring the fact
that the protesters are setting up
barricades and burning crap
like literally setting things on fire
and resisting
federal officers and local officers but
we have to focus in on naked athena the
weird naked lady doing yoga poses
standing as a symbol of freedom
against these brutal tyrants we have to
focus in on the moms the moms first of
all let me just say to you you
antifa protesters out there if you're
calling your mommy
because you're too much of a pansy to
actually just take the brunt of
what you're dishing out you have to call
your mommy to stand as your human shield
your your wimp your wimp uh all your
faux masculinity you're a wimp
is standing with a pack of other
protesters she chanted in front of the
boarded up entrance to the federal
courthouse she remained resolute even as
someone the crowd began prying at the
wood affixed to the building
leaving miss hyder uneasy about where
things were headed i am the face of
anarchy ms hyder declared the people of
the us need to know moms grandmas nurses
are out here in the middle of the night
demanding rights for everybody
okay so we're gonna focus in on her like
isn't the buried headline there that
people are prying away boards from the
federal courthouse to try and vandalize
it again
wouldn't that be the headline the
demonstrations that have shuttered
through
portland for 54 consecutive nights have
drawn out a complicated mix of
grievances as says the new york times
with a wide array of people expressing
them
using a multitude of tactics to make
sure they get hurt uh it's just a way of
getting heard guys
you see if anti-lockdown protesters like
to show up and say things
then they're bad racist people who are
endangering other people if you show up
to a federal courthouse and try to burn
it down that's just your way of being
heard
don't you see how this works and if you
call your mommy to protect you that's
because you're so brave
because really these protesters are all
six year old moms they're not a bunch of
white kids woke white kids who are
living in their parents basement
and masturbating to anime in oregon a
state with a deep history of racism that
included racial exclusion laws extending
into the 20th century the portland
protests have persisted since george
floyd's killing even as blm
demonstrations have waned in many other
parts of the country
okay alternatively antique has been
making trouble in this area for
literally years on end
some leaders in the black community
grateful for a widespread discussion on
race worry that what should be a moment
for racial justice in portland could be
squandered by violence oh you think
oh you think the city's mayor ted
wheeler is angry because the feds are
coming in so
here's what's happening chaos in the
streets of portland and when president
trump steps in
then we hear that president trump is the
bad guy so oregon's governor
said to the feds governor cape branch
said we want you to go home how about
this
call out these state troopers you are
the governor of the state
are you okay with the chaos that you are
seeing in the streets of portland
apparently the answer is yes because so
long as you can just rip
on on trump everything is good to go
here's governor kate brown
being a horrible public servant a
horrible public servant but
again she's not serving the public she's
serving her own political interest in
the interests of her party
when i spoke to the secretary of
homeland security last week
i told them to go home that their forces
are not needed here they are not wanted
here
and they're making a challenging
situation worse
as i said the violence is absolutely
unacceptable
we're talking about outliers uh in terms
of protesters
but in oregon you know we solve problems
by sitting down
we solve problems by de-escalating a
situation
and engaging in dialogue and what in the
f is this lady talking about they've
been rolling riots in her cities
for 54 straight days she sounds exactly
like the mayor of
seattle jenny durkin who sort of
whistled past the graveyard on chop up
until the point where people started
getting shot to death
in the middle of her major city joe
biden by the way
this should be such a winning issue for
trump because guess what most americans
don't like this crap they do not like
watching federal courthouses get burned
they do not like chaos in their streets
they're not fond of any of this
and joe biden is embracing the suck i
mean he really is joe biden put out a
statement he's been pretty careful
about what he says on this sort of stuff
because he doesn't want to appear
like a radical but what he has said on
what's going on in portland
is truly insane he has sailed president
trump and his administration for quote
brutally attacking peaceful protesters
and using egregious tactics in response
to recent demonstrations in portland
oregon he put out a statement to
buzzfeed he said we have a president who
is determined to sow chaos and division
to make matters worse
instead of better he said we all
remember the appalling scenes in front
of the white house when peaceful
protests were
protesters were gassed to make way for a
trump photo op
now homeland security agents without a
clearly defined mandate or authority are
ranging far from federal property
stripped of badges and insignia and
identifying markings to detain people
they are brutally attacking peaceful
protesters including
a u.s navy veteran okay that's not true
okay that's not true they are fully
identified they have police badges on
them if you look at their shoulders they
have insignia that explain which branch
of the government they are from
in fact here is a dhs official yesterday
cracking back
on on joe biden's idiot statements here
the the fact is not only is there
statutory authority for what the feds
are doing right here they are
identifying themselves and they do have
the authority to do it
here is a dhs official explaining
yesterday this is the identity
identification every single one of them
has on their uniform
and this is a baseline director kline
said he doesn't have his officers
wearing name tags because they're being
dots
that's exactly right that's another
thing that's absolutely disgusting
so they're not only jeopardizing the
lives of the agents
but they're also jeopardizing the lives
of their families as they're putting out
their home information
and they're suggesting that individuals
go to their homes
so yes i as the acting commissioner have
authorized and supported removing their
names from their uniform instead what we
have though
is a personal identifier okay so he is
correct about this but we've heard from
biden that it's it's the fascists in the
streets the jack boots
in the streets kaylee mackinnani over at
the white house yesterday she said by
the way we do have statutory authority
for this
their statutory authority to assist
department of homeland security
by shifting forces from for example
customs and border patrol
and like their statutory authority idiot
jamel bowie at the new york times of
course has a piece talking about how
this is just awful and a violation of
all right all law
he admits by the way in his column that
there is lawful authority to do all this
stuff and lots of precedent he says the
difference lies less in the acts
themselves than in the way these events
developed
use of military force against strikers
and protesters is certainly
controversial but for the most part it
unfolds along
clear lines of responsibility and
involves powers expressly granted to the
president
okay the president does have the ability
under the insurrection act to call in
federal forces to quell
exactly the sort of activity there is
statutory authority there have been no
constitutional allegations of violations
jamel bowie just doesn't like it because
trump's doing it and because he is
sympathetic to the goals
of the people who are militating in
favor of chaos
this is a secret of nationwide police
force created without congressional
input or authorization
formed from highly politicized agencies
highly politicized agencies by the way
according to
jamel bowie means agencies where people
are sympathetic to trump
that's what highly politicized means so
the state department which is
very much a left-leaning department not
highly politicized ice
because there are a lot of people who
support trump highly politicized
according to chamel buoy which means
they're bad
which means they're a tyrannical wing of
the us government anyway here's kaylee
mackinnani explaining yes in fact there
is legal authority to do this
what you're referring to is portland and
40 u.s code 1315 gives dhs
the ability to deputize officers in any
department or agency
like ice custom and border patrol and
secret service quote as officers and
agents they can be deputized for the
duty
of uh in connection with the protection
of property owned or occupied by the
federal government and persons on that
property and when a federal courthouse
is being
lit on fire commercial fireworks being
shot at it being shot at the officers
i think that that falls pretty well
within uh the limits of 40 u.s code
1350.
right and she's talking specifically
about u.s code that prevents the assault
of federal property
and she's correct about this there is
authority to do this nonetheless as we
will see democrats
are militating in favor of the rioters
and looters which means they're rooting
for the chaos
they want the chaos the chaos is good
for them politically and they are happy
to castigate
as gestapo members of federal law
enforcement who are identified as such
and at this point you have to say these
are folks in the democratic party in the
media promulgating this narrative who do
not care about law abiding citizens
they don't they're willing to abandon
law abiding citizens in favor of rioters
and looters
so i don't know where you would put them
on the good for america
scale but i don't think it would be on
the good for america side particularly
because this isn't good for america
it ain't we'll get some more of this in
just one second first
did you know that a hacker strikes every
39 seconds stealing for things like
videos passwords files you name it they
want you've ever been hacked it is no
fun at all now
take a second to think about the private
information you've got on your computer
and mobile devices
pictures videos financial information
your work files your personal documents
all of that is being targeted every 39
seconds by hackers so what exactly are
you doing
to keep that from happening you need
protection pcmatic is doing it right
they know that hackers are constantly
striking and attack methods are always
changing which is why pcmatic does it
differently
pcmatic protects your devices by only
permitting known trusted programs
to run no matter how many times the
hackers try pcmatic keeps them out and
your information safe
they're the only anti-virus company that
does its development research customer
support 100
in the united states when it comes to
cyber attacks it is a question of
not if but when so what exactly are you
waiting for pcmatic will protect your
mac or your windows computer server
android phones tablets all of it
get a free month of protection right now
with the purchase of an annual license
at pcmatic.com again you gotta protect
your information on your like this is a
big thing i've been hacked before it is
no fun
go to pcmatic.com and keep the bad guys
out and your personal information secure
with pcmatic go to pcmatic.com get a
free month of protection when you get
that annual license okay in just a
second
we're gonna get to the continuing the
continuing support for chaos it is it is
a wild thing
i haven't seen anything quite like this
since the ferguson stuff
during the ferguson riots the remembers
the democratic party who are sort of
rooting for it
but not this clearly not to the point
where the president
issues federal orders to shut it down
and the democrats are
overtly calling members of federal law
enforcement gestapo it's pretty it's
pretty insane we'll get to this in one
second first
as you know my new book how to destroy
america in three easy steps it is on
sale
right now it premiered yesterday already
at the top of the charts
tens of thousands of copies already the
book covers two fundamentally different
visions of america that are now on the
table you're watching them in action
one is a vision of america that finds
unity
and and a and a sense of country and
nation
in a shared philosophy culture and
history and the other looks at all those
things as bad
we can't have a shared philosophy we
can't share a culture we can't share our
history
american history is replete with racism
and bigotry american philosophy is
rooted
in brutal exploitation american culture
needs to be overturned
in favor of a better vision for humanity
disintegrationists use weapons like
cancel culture deleting or silencing
people or anyone that disagrees with
them to build a whole new world order
you're seeing all this play out
not just in the businesses of america
but in the streets of america when i
wrote this book i didn't realize it
would be prophetic it sort of is how to
destroy america in three easy steps it
not only details how this alternative
worldview has gained so much ground so
quickly it also offers a view of the
culture at this point in our history
that is necessary and
the antidote i think the book itself is
the antidote to so much of what you're
seeing
if somebody you know has been prescribed
to white fragility instead
hand them a copy of my book which is
number one not demagogic nonsense and
number two actually readable go check it
out right now you can pick it up at
amazon or at barnes noble
right now also you may have noticed this
year
crazy the writers of 2020 they just blew
it out they went into their trunk they
took out all the story lines and they
just dumped it all in
at once and the media are lying to you
on a regular basis right they're saying
portland is peaceful
up until the feds got there they're
saying kova 19 going to kill everyone
unless we lock down full scale and it's
the trump virus well when you can't get
the real story
you do have to go outside the narrative
and get the facts so if you're a
political junkie set on getting both
sides of the story get a reader's pass
today from dailywire.com you'll get
access to exclusive op-eds from us
your podcast house as well as guest
writers in-depth analysis from the daily
wire reporters on top of our regular
breaking news my latest article was a
piece specifically about the dissolution
of the country it should be out today
this membership to your already a
bargain at three bucks a month if you
join today you get your first month for
99 cents
under a buck you also get access to the
mobile app you receive push
notifications for breaking news
and special content as well as joining
the community of daily wire members who
are actively commenting and discussing
our content with each other
that's mobile ad free access to all
daily wire news exclusive op-eds
all the podcasts on the mobile app all
for the low price of one dollar and best
of all
your bucks are getting you the news you
need without the crazy disintegration to
spin so head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe and join today you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so as i say the chaos is across
the country right it is not just in
portland chicago is completely chaotic
which drove president trump to say
yesterday listen if i have to deploy
federal agents to chicago to stop the
chaos i'll deploy federal agents to
chicago to stop the chaos
which by the way he probably needs to do
here was trump
how about chicago i read the numbers
were
many people killed over the weekend
we're looking at chicago too would you
say they need help after this weekend do
you know the numbers did you hear the
numbers
many many shot many many killed
many i'm not talking about one two
was it 18 people killed i think more
than that
and you ended up over the summer this is
worse than
afghanistan by far this is worse than
anything anyone's ever seen okay so lori
lightfoot the mayor of chicago she
immediately
starts screaming about this on twitter
says under no circumstances will i allow
donald trump's troops
to come to chicago and terrorize our
residents really what you're gonna do
really what you're going to do you're
going to deploy the chicago pd to fight
off
america's federal law enforcement trying
to enforce the law
yes clearly the threat to chicago
citizens comes from federal law
enforcement trying to enforce the law
probably that's the big issue oh yeah by
the way last week
18 police officers were injured at a
chicago quote unquote protest
the police said that they were
outnumbered and unprepared is according
to cnn
approaching a statute of christopher
columbus some people in the crowd use
rocks fireworks frozen bottles
and other objects to attack officers
according to a statement from the pd
18 officers were injured some were taken
to area hospitals by paramedics for
further treatment
some were treated at the scene at a news
conference saturday activists demanded
the immediate to funding of the police
department
oh yeah and by the way literally as
laurie lightfoot the idiot mayor of
chicago
terrible mayor of chicago was talking
about how she doesn't want
federal law enforcement in her city at
least 16 people were shot at a chicago
funeral home
the gunfire according to breaking 911
broke out at the graham funeral home
located at 1018 west 79th street in the
city's auburn gresham neighborhood
according to cbs2 there was some kind of
planned ambush outside the funeral home
where a memorial service was going on
for a homicide victim
chicago fire department reports at least
11 victims taken to the hospital all
listed
in various condition so good times over
in chicago but the problem obviously
obviously is president trump
right when trump says we need to use
federal power to protect the life
liberty and property of the citizenry of
the united states
democrats are fighting back against that
they're fighting back against that now
you want to say listen we're doing it
ourselves that'd be one thing but you're
not doing it yourselves you're talking
about defunding your own police
and in some areas letting looters and
rioters run roughshod through your major
cities
and then you're ripping on trump this is
trump's fault listen to the insane
statement
put out by nancy pelosi and
representative earl blumenauer of
portland oregon
as our nation mourns the loss of our
colleague and beloved civil rights
leader john lewis we are again reminded
of the immense power of peaceful protest
in the fight against racial injustice
and police brutality
this is not peaceful protest in portland
they're attempting to burn down the
local courthouse
every night they're committing acts of
vandalism they're committing acts of
property destruction they're committing
acts of violence
that is not what john lewis did to
defame john lewis by suggesting that
sitting
at a segregated lunch counter in protest
is the same thing as firing fireworks at
a federal courthouse is patently nuts it
is nuts it is insane
it's it's i have to say the gaslighting
that is now being engaged in by
democrats in the media is totally wild
so on the one hand they say well you
know these protests are mostly protest
they're mostly peaceful
now again that term is such it's such
mush
mostly peaceful you know like as i've
said before o.j simpson the night he
killed
his ex-wife mostly peaceful that night
like for the hours between sunset and
sunrise
mostly a peaceful night it was really
that like you know 45-minute gap right
in the middle where it got really not
peaceful but most of the night was
peaceful
like what exactly is that supposed to
mean if you want to say there's a
difference between protesters and the
writers and looters
totally on board totally agree but then
you can't just pretend that the writing
and the looting doesn't exist or when it
does happen
say that that's part of the generalized
protest and hope that we're not going to
notice what you just did right there
you either have to separate the two
groups or you have to conflate the two
groups you do not get to do some
sometimes one and sometimes the other
whatever floats your boat
according to nancy pelosi she says time
and time again the trump administration
shows its lack of respect for the
dignity and first amendment rights of
all americans
last month the administration
tear-gassed peaceful protesters in
washington dc
again the president should not have had
the park service
used tear gas to disperse peaceful
protesters in washington square park
or in lafayette park rather it is also
true
that according to the park service there
were objects being thrown at the police
officers at the time but
here's where it goes crazy even if you
think that was bad that is not the same
thing as we're deploying federal
officers
who are clearly labeled as such to
enforce the law when people are
violating it
now listen to this language from nancy
pelosi this is nuts videos show them
kidnapping protesters in unmarked cars
in portland
all with the goal of inflaming tensions
from their own gain no
they are detaining and arresting
suspects that is perfectly legal
where are the civil rights lawsuits
seriously where are they normally when
someone gets detained
without any cause whatsoever and then
arrested are these people going to gitmo
what happened to all of them
where are all the horror stories from
people who are being unjustly
rounded up and sent to gitmo where are
they they don't exist because it ain't
happening
while portland is the president's
current target any city could be next
could it could it really
you really think that any city is going
to be next or maybe it's the city where
there have been 54 days of running
rioting maybe it's that one
i mean just out of the blue i'm just
gonna i'm gonna say it's probably that
one
we live in a democracy not a banana
republic says nancy pelosi
the leader of the banana republic says
we will not tolerate the use of
oregonians washingtonians or any other
americans
as props in trump's political games you
know the real props are the american
citizenry
law-abiding american citizens those are
the props like for example
you know who's a prop a prop is horus
lorenzo anderson jr a 19 year old black
man shot and killed
in the capitol occupied protest zone for
weeks we were told that chop chaz
was the newest element of the of the
beautiful leftist revolution that we
were seeing we were told that it was
basically a city street fair
according to mayor jenny durkin when
trump said i'll send in the feds
the democrats like you can't do that
this is a beautiful outpouring of
democracy
and then people started getting shot
well now danita sinclair martin
the mother of horus lorenzo anderson jr
is suing the city of seattle
because city officials abandoned the six
block autonomous zone leaving her
injured and bleeding son to wait for
emergency care that never arrived
the seattle times reports the mother of
the 19 year old seattle man fatally shot
in chop chaz
filed a wrongful death claim against the
city of seattle alleging city officials
created a dangerous environment
yeah you think you think anderson and
another man a 33 year old were shot
multiple times near the boundary of the
chop
zone but protesters blocked emergency
vehicles and other first responders from
attending to lorenzo anderson junior
you're never going to hear about lorenzo
anderson jr
from the democratic party you're just
not going to hear about him
just disappears just disappears because
the narrative is that trump is a fascist
and so we will foster chaos
just so that when trump responds we'll
call him a fascist this is what kamala
harris was doing last night
she again the democrats are lying to you
they're lying to you and they say that
this is just about trump's silencing
protest
did i miss the part where um over the
last eight weeks you saw literally
probably tens of millions of people in
the streets in the middle of a pandemic
protesting and nothing happening to them
i mean i live in la we shut down the
entire city of los angeles
not just so that protesters could go out
in violation of pandemic code
but so that protesters could turn into
rioters and looters and completely
ransack melrose boulevard
like i am old enough to remember that
because i'm more than four weeks old
but now senator kamala harris from my
state of california she said let's be
clear what trump is doing he's trying to
silence and punish
those protesting police brutality and
demanding racial justice across our
country
yesterday i joined my colleagues on a
bill to block the trump administration
from deploying paramilitary forces
against americans
this is purely insane i mean it's it's
just crazy it's just crazy
and frankly it should be a winning issue
for trump because if the democrats
insist
on embracing actual chaos and violence
and labeling america's federal law
enforcement gestapo
which is what james clyburn of south
carolina did yesterday
then i don't know what to tell you i
don't think most americans stand with
that
i really don't i think americans are
willing to virtue signal about how much
they dislike the police up until the
point
when their property is getting burned
and at that point they're like you know
what i think we could use the cops right
now
just a little bit and meanwhile
the the house gop is in a state of
disarray like you'd think now would be a
pretty good time to be unified
apparently not because everything
revolves around trump so yesterday
members of the conservative house
freedom caucus according to politico
tore into representative liz cheney
during a heated gop conference meeting
on tuesday
lobbing attacks at her for breaking with
president trump supporting dr anthony
fauci and backing a primary opponent to
one of their colleagues
representative jordan of ohio freedom
caucus co-founder one of trump's top
allies called out cheney the gop
conference chair for all the times she
has opposed trump
and began taking off some recent
high-profile examples while jordan
praised her defense of trump during
impeachment
he also said cheney's recent rebukes of
trump which have focused on trump's
handling of coronavirus twitter rhetoric
and foreign policy
were not helpful representative annie
biggs of arizona head of the freedom
caucus even accused
cheney of undermining the gop's ability
to win back the house
instead if someone has a problem with
trump they should keep it to themselves
cheney responded by disagreeing with
jordan's assessment
cheney said i look forward to hearing
your comments about being a team player
when we're back in the majority
okay if you're directing your ire
at liz cheney for pointing out when
trump does stuff that is wrong
that's political malfeasance i think
there are two very different views on
how people are going to
maintain the the house minority maybe
win a majority
one is you tie yourself to trump i do
not see the evidence that this is going
to be a successful electoral strategy
the polling does not suggest it the
republicans tied themselves to the mass
of trump in 2018 and they got absolutely
shellacked it was a blue wave
liz cheney drawing some distance and
doing what i think is the proper thing
and saying
of course i support the president of the
united states on policy but when he says
dumb things i don't support that
that's where most americans are and just
because trump threatens people with
twitter
does not mean that the the strongest
strategy for senators who are up for
reelection and in
battleground states or house members who
are in purple district the best strategy
is to tie themselves to trump's leg to
staple trump to their pant leg and if
liz cheney provides cover to some of
those members
and supports some of those members they
can win those seats that's a good thing
not a bad thing
again i like all the people who are
talking about right now i'm very
friendly with every single member we
have talked about right now
but let's just say that if you don't
have any ideological diversity inside
the republican party with regard to
trump himself as a figure you're doing
it wrong
and president trump himself should
understand this right if trump wins he's
going to want a house majority that
actually supports him
if trump wins he's going to want
senators that support him
the last thing he should be doing right
now is attacking senators or house
members who show insufficient loyalty
who refuse to bend the knee
i mean that that and and house members
should not be cuddling each other
into you have to support everything with
regard to president trump like matt getz
tweeted liz cheney has worked behind the
scenes against donald trump and his
agenda
house republicans deserve better in our
conference chair this cheney should be
should step down or be removed i
disagree
disagree i don't see what liz cheney has
done wrong here and disagreeing with the
president
on some of the things he has said seems
frankly like a fairly good idea when he
says things that are not correct
i mean for goodness sake the president
of the united states went out yesterday
and
expressed sympathy for chilean maxwell
who was the accomplice to jeffrey
epstein the procurer
for jeffrey epstein like are republicans
supposed to defend this because that
seems like a bad electoral strategy to
me here was the president yesterday
saying that he wishes the best to jizz
lane maxwell who was by all allegations
procuring underage girls for jeffrey
epstein's rape
yeah this is not a good look for the
president my goodness
do you feel that she's going to turn in
powerful men how do you see that working
out
i don't know i haven't really been
following it too much i just wish her
well frankly
i've met her numerous times over the
years especially since i lived in palm
beach and
i guess they lived in palm beach uh but
i wish her well
whatever it is uh i don't know the
situation with prince andrew
just don't know not aware of it okay so
yeah again
that is not a good look and if liz
cheney's like ah i don't like those
comments i don't think she needs to be
shellacked for something like that
obviously and again republican unity
does not mean that you have to be
unified on everything trump related it
means you should be unified in the face
of the big issues like
democrats being in favor of people
burning down cities seems like that
should be a point of unity
okay time for a quick thing that i like
this is sponsored by the benjamin
brothers learn how to own a business
without it owning you get 15
discount on the benefit brothers new
course expert ownership at
beninbrothers.com
ben again 15 discounts on their new
course expert ownership at
bennenbrothers.com
ben so i love my sabbath the reason i
love my sabbath i can go through a
thousand books
ugh it's just great i read three books
over over sabbath
last week it was just fantastic one of
them is particularly good
it's called false alarm by bjorn lomberg
i highly recommend it it's called how
climate change panic
costs us trillions hurts the poor and
fails to fix the planet so bjorn lombard
is not in fact a climate change denier
he believes that climate change is
largely man-made
he believes that it is happening and he
goes through the statistics using as his
model all of the un information
and that human information talks about
the warming of the climate over the
course of the next hundred years
he also has the temerity to challenge a
lot of the preconceived notions that are
being put out there a lot of the myths
about
the the amazon being the lungs of the
world and how all of that is dying
the preconceived notion that weather is
getting
significantly more extreme because of
global warming that the costs
of weather getting more extreme are due
to the
the changing of the climate dramatically
as opposed to people building in the way
and one of the statistics you'll often
see is hurricanes are more damaging now
than they ever have been
well hurricanes actually are not more
common now than they are than they ever
have been by data
there are some hurricanes that are more
powerful but the real reason they're
more damaging
is because people have built in the path
of the hurricanes there's a lot more
people living in miami now than were
living in miami in 1900 for example
he also pushes back against the notion
they're going to have
millions upon millions of climate
refugees that the rise of the oceans
over the course of the next 100 years
is going to flood all outlying areas all
over the world
he points out that there are some fairly
low-cost things that we can do to
fight back against climate change right
certain things
are are more out there like
geo-engineering right that'd be the
attempt to control the climate
but there there which there's fairly
good evidence we can do that but we're
still figuring out whether there are any
downsides that would be you know firing
sulfur basically in the air to to create
cloud cover which would presumably lower
the temperature for example
but other things are less out there
right beyond innovation beyond
innovation of new products and services
that will
lower the cost of so-called green energy
which by the way is not going to come in
the form of wind or solar it's going to
be other forms of energy probably
but what he talks about mostly is
mitigation right mitigation is low-cost
stuff now you'll never hear
people in positions of power who are
pushing on the global warming stuff
point
talk about the fact that the paris
climate accords if implemented in their
entirety
would lower the changed climate by the
end of the century
by i believe 0.0.5 degrees celsius
0.5 degrees celsius at the cost of
trillions and trillions of dollars
okay but what they'll never mention is
that there's certain things that we can
do that are a lot cheaper that actually
protects human beings
you can build better sea walls for
example you can build more dikes
you can you can make sure that low-lying
areas are better protected
so this is really a myth buster's book
it is really really worth reading
he goes through again a lot of the talk
about what exactly is true and what is
false
on climate change and his his thesis is
should we worry about climate change
sure should we panic about climate
change absolutely not
and he is right about all of this he
tends to cite exactly the same folks
i've cited before william nordhaus of
yale university
just won the economics nobel prize for
his work on climate change
and he points out that there are costs
to policy and you have to actually look
at what are the costs of global warming
versus what are the cost of implementing
the policy which means
that when the ipcc or the un says we
have to keep the climate from increasing
by 1.5 degrees celsius
over the course of the next century that
is undoable and would be incredibly
stupid it would be actually
counterproductive to do that
it will cost far more in terms of growth
to the world
to take the measures being talked about
essentially ending the use of
carbon-based fossil fuels
it would cost much more particularly to
the developing world than it would just
let climate change happen
and there's sort of a sweet spot in
terms of how much you can
lower climate change through things like
carbon credits and tax
tax basis and and mitigation efforts
there's sort of a sweet spot there
and we are nowhere near the sweet spots
when you hear the climate alarmist when
you hear greta thunderberg
suggesting that we have to basically end
all life on earth in order to prevent
the end of all life on earth she's just
speaking
from a position of ignorance it's just
not correct so
this is uh the book is well worth the
read again it is a realistic take on
climate change that everybody should
take a look at false alarm by bjorn
lumber go pick up a copy right now okay
we'll be back here later today with two
additional hours of content
much more to get to then in the meantime
go pick up a copy of my brand new book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps
surging up the charts over at amazon and
all over
the united states and we will see you
here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinterton
edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hillary peddles an election conspiracy
theory joe biden wants islam taught in
schools
and the feds finally start arresting
anarchists check it out on the michael
knoll show